you had this extraordinary scene that
they were due to play a playoff game
against the orlando magic it was to take
place within the nba's
bubble it's a corones carnivorous free
zone in orlando at the moment where all
of the nba games were taking place
the orlando players were in court
warming up there was no sign of the
bucks players for a while
then the word began to emerge that they
had held meetings and discussions
about whether it would be a fitting
protest to not play the game
due to what had happened so very close
to milwaukee did the shooting of jacob
lake just
40 miles outside the city where the
bucks call their home
and the word came from the locker room
that they would not take
take the court and an extraordinary turn
of events following that the two other
games due to be played yesterday were
also called off and the nba an impasse
amongst this fight for racial justice
into which so
much of the players hopes and and dreams
have been invested
yeah i mean it's hard to know i suppose
in that moment how much the
administrators were working in concert
with the players but i note this quote
from
the buck senior vp alex lasry who
tweeted
the stand taken by the players shows
that we're fed up enough is enough
change needs to happen i'm incredibly
proud of our guys we stand 100
behind our players ready to assist and
bring about real change so
it's not always been the case has it
that if you think back to the nfl
american football
some of the take the knee protest didn't
always enjoy universal support from
within
the club no but the nfl
a very different animal i mean the the
the treatment that colin kaepernick
received
very different to the attitude that the
nba has traditionally shown to its
players over the years they
its players have been very engaged in
this fight
for racial justice for social justice
you can go back to the 1960s
when the likes of bill russell kareem
and joel debar were shoulders your
shoulder
in the civil rights movement alongside
muhammad ali today's players
very much engaged we've seen where in in
recent
times when george floyd's killing
brought people onto the streets
nba players were out in public they
weren't just tweeting they weren't just
talking on television they were out on
the streets helping to protest lebron
james
though arguably the most famous player
in basketball the moment has been front
and centrist the league has been very
keen to encourage that they have not
held back in their players they have
worked with him
inside the bubble in in orlando black
lives matters is painted on the court
each of the players
has had social messages on their jersey
it has been lockstep and now these two
things are coming together
uh in orlando in a very visible form
and mark for people who don't follow
professional basketball in the states
where are we in terms of the schedule
how it affects things like the playoffs
what's the impact
well right now there are two meetings as
we understand it going on in orlando one
involving all the owners but the players
are effectively in the room it will be a
zoom call of some court but they are
they're all talking together
the players who met last night as a
group
the the teams who are left in the
players are also meeting as well to
decide what
they do next now last night the players
after they all returned from from the
court
there were discussions a couple of teams
the la clifford the los angeles
lakers as well we understand that they
were broadly in favor of calling off the
season
other teams other players considering
that that would be
too drastic a step no i think the mood
is from what you hear from players over
there
is that they want the the player the
owners the teams to be
much more influential to do more and and
see what they can do to influence
lawmakers the bucks last night
while they were in the locker room had a
conference call with lawmakers
in wisconsin to try and put forward
their case for it for tougher
accountability for the police as they
said no what hangs in the balance now we
don't know tonight if tonight's games go
ahead and we're just
three four five hours away from the
start of those we don't know if the rest
of this season will be called off
huge financial implications if that
happened but there is frustration for
the players they are locked inside this
bubble
they would dearly love to be engaged on
a more hands-on basis
and some of them feel that they would
rather be outside now
rather than trapped inside in a sense
you